match de gala à elancourt le club local
a accueilli ce samedi 24 septembre au
stade guy-boniface les réserves d'eau
serré de caen deux équipes qui évoluent
en nationale 3 l'équivalent de la
cinquième division
un match amical organisé dans le cadre
d'un partenariat avec les bourguignons
sa part dans un partenariat qui existe
depuis trois ans et demi bien maintenant
le mois février 2014
donc voilà c'est un apport en support
technique en plus pour retourner aussi
éducateur et pour nos joueurs c'est
important aussi car voilà de temps en
temps et détection qui s'organise chez
nous donc c'est des possibilités en plus
pour nous pour nos joueurs
certains joueurs du club ont pu profiter
de ces détections pour rejoindre les
professionnels c'est le cas de françois
xavier founou tamouz au 22 ans
aujourd'hui joueur de l'aja pour le voir
en action sur le terrain de ses débuts
des centaines de supporters ont fait le
déplacement
en fait c'est un petit jeune qui a
commencé dans le football avec mon
frangin mon petit frère
et voilà depuis on le suit et puis on
apprécier ce qui fait quoi
ces pousses souffland et on a la chance
d'aller voir les matches à auxerre et
franchement avoir suivi sa carrière et
et pouvoir le voir du haut des gradins
franchement connu avec les jeunes
il joue avec mon fils tout ça devrait
m'aider à la même équipe donc je le
suivais sur ce match donc pour ces morts
ça fait plaisir
le match s'est terminé sur un score de
parité un but partout entre les cannes
et les auxerrois
d'autres rencontres amicales échos serre
pourraient être organisées dans les
prochains mois